Welcome back to six zero,
nine,
nine artificial general intelligence.
Today we have Mark Graber.
Thank you.
He is the.
He really doesn't need an introduction,
but we'll give him one.
Anyway,
he's the founder and CEO,
CEO of Boston Dynamics.
He founded the Cmu leg lab in 1980,
the mit leg lab in 1986.
Boston dynamics in 1992.
He and his team have developed some of
the most amazing robots ever built,
including big dog atlas handle spots,
spot many.
These robots move with the agility,
dexterity,
and even grace that rivals and often
supersedes that of human movement.
He continues to inspire us with what
robots are capable of achieving in the
real world and what physical form future
intelligence systems may take as they
become integrated in our daily lives.
So please give a warm welcome.
Thank you.
This is our grand mission or aspiration,
which is to make robots that are equal
to or greater than a people in animals.
And it's,
you know,
it's a daunting mission because a,
we're so good at things.
It seems effortless.
You know,
I'm standing here.
No one questions that I could stand here
like this,
but a lot's going on,
I can manipulate things,
I can pick up this water,
I could reach in my pocket and use my
hands with all the sensors in my hands
and coordinate that and maybe most of
all our perception systems,
you know,
there's audience has,
what is it,
250 people in it or something.
And I can look out there and see every
one of you a stabilized in space even
while I'm moving.
It's a,
it's just astounding.
And the,
you know,
robots aren't there yet,
but I think they can be.
And uh,
our goal is to keep chipping away,
uh,
to try and get there.
Before I get started,
I wanted to say that I got my start in
robotics,
uh,
here at Mit.
I was a graduate student.
I was in the,
what was then called the psychology
department,
the brain and cognitive sciences
department.
But I was taking an iap course just like
you are.
And it might've been a,
you know,
exactly this time of year when I
followed one of my professor burt told
Horn back,
I had,
I was jabbering away at him asking him
some questions about this or that.
And we walked back to tech square,
which is where the AI lab was in those
days.
And uh,
we went up to the ninth floor and
Russell Oscar,
who was a guy working in the lab,
had an arm all taken apart on the table.
It was like a thousand pieces.
And I was a roboticist from that day on.
I swear I didn't switch my major by,
uh,
you know,
got bertold to be an advisor.
I found a topic that had to do with
robotics in that time.
It was a manipulation thing,
but eventually became legged,
uh,
thing.
And uh,
it was amazing,
you know,
and,
uh,
I've never looked back.
So,
um,
here are some animals doing things that
are a very exciting climbing around on
very rough terrain.
A very sure footed,
using a mixture of their proprioception
and their vision.
And look,
there's even a baby that probably is
only a couple of months old,
has no trouble at all doing these
things.
And a look at the grace and suppleness
and,
uh,
the fearlessness of,
of these animals.
It's amazing here are animals running
for their lives.
Uh,
the Gazelle is trying to stay alive for
the next 10 minutes and the cheetahs
trying to get a meal so that it can stay
alive in general.
And uh,
you know,
even people can do things,
uh,
that are breathtec.
I assume all of you were out this
morning getting a little exercise,
climbing up the green building that
we're in now.
And then maybe the other places around
here.
It's funny,
I had bumped into some people when I
came into the room who were climbing the
stairways,
I think that were going on a trek up and
down them.
But I'd like to see the going outside.
So probably most of you have seen this
video.
This is a,
this is sort of where we were after
about 10 years of work thing to make
machines that could work out in the real
world that we're dynamically stabilize
dynamics is a big deal for our company
and for what we do.
So,
uh,
some active sensing and control and
understanding of the physics.
Um,
here's,
this robot has all this control on board
and it has reflexes and sensors and this
is an extension a to a thousand pound
robot that could carry about 400 pounds
of payload.
And we took it all around the United
States,
testing it,
uh,
in various situations.
Uh,
here we have it in Virginia doing some
bushwhacking.
It's actually following a person,
but the person is only in that have you
intermittently.
So it has to be able to keep track of
where the person is and a deal with
that.
And then back in good old Boston,
10 inches of snow just marches right up
the hill.
Here's the Cheetah.
And now you know,
mit has its own cheetah.
This is our cheetah.
Uh,
the people,
no Song Bay who's doing the Mit Cheetah,
um,
a very dynamic machine and basically an
experiment and seeing how fast we could
make something like this run,
although you notice it's on a parking
lot,
so it wasn't doing this on rough terrain
and getting both efficiency and the
speed in,
in the context of machine they'd also
can do rough terrain is a really big
challenge that remains with us.
So this is just a snapshot of a most of
the robots that we built at Boston
dynamics over the years.
And uh,
I'm not going to talk about most of
them.
I'm just going to talk about the last
four.
Uh,
these are all robots that we developed
since we'd been part of Google,
which has been the last four years.
A spot many.
There's a spot on the floor here which
we'll demo the later spot.
Atlas,
the humanoid.
Some of you may remember the humanoid
that we used in the Darpa robotics
challenge.
You have one here and uh,
and then handle it,
which is our latest version.
So I'll say a few words to say about
each of them.
So we had been developing a big dog and
those other quieter peds that I showed
you for quite some number of years and
it was amazing for us to find out when
we did this project on a spot,
this is the predecessor to that,
that there was still a lot to learn and
we kind of revolutionize the hardware
design and how the control worked and
got a much higher level of rough terrain
performance.
And part of the solution to that was to
be able to decompose the control problem
into a many separate controllers that
operated in different regions of state
space.
Uh,
and that allowed us both to have
programmers work on multiple solutions
to the problem.
I'm a and also have the complexity of
each controller is simplified by only
having to operate in a small part of the
dynamic space here.
We've added a robot arm to the,
to the previous version of spot.
Um,
and uh,
you know,
we believe that mobile manipulation that
is manipulation when you can move the
base is really a powerful,
a way of doing things.
Now,
this is probably the most important
thing I want to show tonight and I'll
show it three different times,
the idea that we don't build controllers
that just do one particular thing,
but that they can determine where they
are in the execution,
here's another version of it,
and then adjust what they're doing in
order to compensate for disturbances in
the real world.
I know this class is about ai and
probably autonomy.
Um,
I think that the,
one of the most important ways of
getting to autonomy is to have the low
level implementation's very robust to
disturbances so that the planning steps
don't have to take care of all the
minutia of the details of the real
world.
And that's what we've been trying to do
there.
Um,
we've been experimenting with doing
delivery of packages to people's houses.
These are all employees of Boston
dynamics,
so we didn't go crashing a ordinary
people's houses.
And,
uh,
it turns out that there's just lots of
different kinds of stairways and
interests ways.
Um,
and uh,
uh,
the robot's doing very well.
We're up to something between 70 and 80
percent of,
uh,
of the kinds of,
stairs and access places we,
uh,
encounter,
um,
after collecting data and making a
improvements and adjustments.
So I'm going to say a few philosophical
things or approach things.
Um,
a lot of people think that this is the
model of how a computer and a robot
interact.
That is,
there's the robot,
uh,
which is hardware and electronics and
sensors and,
uh,
and then there's a computer and that the
computer,
I'm listens to the sensors on the robot
and then gives it instructions and tells
it what to do.
And while I think that's actually going
on,
there's another part to the story which
is that the physical world is also
giving instructions to the robot.
And that means that the energy's stored
in the robot,
either in its springs or in.
It's a,
uh,
it's motion.
Those are all important determinants of
how the robot is going to behave,
uh,
in the time coming forward.
And so we like to think in terms of
designing the hardware of the robot,
the physical world,
and the computer all as one holistic
thing where we take into account the,
those interactions.
Sometimes we call this a harmony,
you know,
a harmonic system is one usually where
you have energy oscillating back and
forth.
Almost all legged locomotion has some
amount of a harmony going on between
potential energy of elevation,
potential energy of elastic deformation,
kinetic energy of motion,
and,
uh,
you know,
inverted pendulum things.
And,
and the like,
uh,
another part of our approach we call
build it,
break it,
fix it.
Now I have friends who build their
robots and are so into the,
the beauty of what they've created that
they kind of put it on an altar and
afraid of actually hurting it.
Uh,
so,
uh,
and in fact,
I even have friends here at mit that
have done that where they have a goal,
play that robot and uh,
they're afraid of taking it out into the
world.
I mean,
we're just the opposite.
Uh,
every one of our robots is designed to
get bashed the bits.
We have staff who are there to fix the
robot on a daily basis,
uh,
as we break it.
And I think doing that build a break it
fix it means that we're able to learn a
lot from the actual physical robot
working in the world and uh,
we can use that knowledge in order to
improve the robot,
improve it's behavior and uh,
we really like to go around that loop as
quickly and as we can early in the,
in the process and do it as many times
as we can.
So here's what build a break it fix.
It looks like a,
this is in Somerville,
our engineers.
This is,
I'm a Boston driver.
Yeah.
This robot's supposed to be using his
visual system to avoid the trees.
I think it might've fallen in love with
this tree.
We don't purposely give them any
emotion,
but boy,
it's hard not to see that.
And here's the first time we tested the
pusher response to this robot.
Did you hear that?
That's the new guy's car.
So some guy who just started that week
trend a have $5,000,
which we paid for,
uh,
in,
in repairs to his vintage BMW.
So the last thing sort of about
philosophy is long term versus short
term.
Uh,
you know,
our company is 25 years old and we've
mostly been a longterm a robotics
company that is,
we're interested in moving the boundary
forward in what robots can do and we're
interested in,
you know,
making it so robots meet the dream of
being the equal or better than people in
animals.
But now we've started function doesn't
break.
Okay,
got it.
We still on.
Can you hear me?
Um,
but uh,
lately we've started to realize that
some of our robots have enough
capability that maybe it's time to try
and productize them and we will learn a
lot by doing that to.
One of the things,
for instance,
that I've always claimed a,
is that we always spent a lot of money
on building our robots in them and use
that as a competitive advantage.
That is,
Darpa was a frequent funder of us.
Darpa always said,
let's take money out of the equation and
just figure out,
um,
uh,
you know,
how to get the solution and then worry
about getting the cost down later.
So I always assumed and argued that once
we get a robot doing things that are
interesting,
then you can go and redesign it to make
it a lower cost.
While we're going,
we're going to test that because it
might not be true.
It might be that we've designed
ourselves into inexpensive coroner and,
uh,
that it might be too late,
but,
uh,
the robot that will show in a little bit
is much significantly cost reduced from
the prototype event.
And it'll be interesting to see whether
we could get it down to the kind of
prices that are useful.
So this is just a picture again,
of the idea of aiming long but also
aiming short and I think it's going to
be a challenge to see whether we can
keep the culture of the company to
support both of these directions because
people manufacturing stuff have a
different mindset than people trying to
get out to the future horizons.
And,
uh,
it's gonna be a challenge to keep both
those kinds of people are happy.
Here's some of the things that,
uh,
some of the kinds of applications you
can look at,
uh,
based on,
um,
modest,
a technical capabilities I've shown
mobility and manipulation here,
but you could put cost,
reliability.
There's many things that could be on
these axes,
you know,
entertainment like robots and theme
parks is something that I think we
should be able to do.
I already talked about home delivery.
I think home delivery is waiting for
self driving cars to get all the way
they are self driving trucks.
And once they do,
then we will be working on getting it
from the truck to the,
to the home.
Um,
logistics,
um,
there's about a trillion boxes moved
every year around the world and most of
it's done by hand.
And so there's really a big opportunity
to having robots help with moving those
trillion box's security,
which could mean either commercial
security,
like patrolling your shopping center or
the military type security,
a construction.
A lot of people have been coming to us
with their construction applications,
a asking if we can help and,
you know,
I'm not going to talk about it now,
but if afterwards you want to ask about
that,
I can fill you in a little more.
And I think this is really the ultimate,
a home run application,
a care for the elderly and the disabled.
Um,
I used to say that I wanted to have
robots that would help me take care of
my,
uh,
my parents and uh,
older people.
But I realize now that it's probably
going to be my children using them to
help take care of me.
But you guys are,
you're all a little bit younger and I
think,
uh,
there'll be a time when,
you could use robots to help make your
parents' lives better.
Now,
some of you may think that your parents
don't want that,
but,
uh,
I think it's a complex question.
We've seen some surveys that say that,
you know,
people aren't totally happy with the
idea of their kids taking care of them
on a moment by moment basis.
And,
uh,
I think there's going to be an
opportunity for doing something,
but technically this is still a ways
off.
It's,
it's a tough thing.
Okay,
let's get back to the robots.
Um,
spot mini is a robot that weighs about
60 pounds that previous spot weight
about 180 pounds.
This one weighs about 60 pounds.
Um,
and uh,
here's some anatomy.
It's got an arm with a five degrees of
freedom.
Each leg has three degrees of freedom.
It's got about a 500 watt hour battery
batteries for these things are
challenged because,
you know,
uh,
you can have consumer products like
electric drills that have relatively
small batteries.
And then there's electric cars that had
big batteries and there's not really
much available in between.
So we've done a lot of work on the
battery technology for these things to
make the safe and reliable and hot
swappable and things like that.
Uh,
then there's radios and computers.
the previous version had three quad
core,
I seven [inaudible].
This one has two.
We're trying to cut back on the cost and
then there can be some sensors,
lidars stereo and the like.
So you can see spot man,
he's a little bit smaller than spot.
Um,
this isn't a real house and those aren't
real people.
Those are engineers.
Um,
this is a inside of a warehouse we have
out on one slash 28 where we've built
the house.
You can see that they don't,
we don't mind scuffing up the walls here
and there is a lot of scuffing that
happens.
Some of you may recognize active Koski
who is a,
uh,
an mit alum and he's again disturbing
the robot here,
the robots using its vision to do some
stepping stone type operations.
And I think gene is going to talk a
little bit more about this in a couple
of minutes.
And here's a case where it's doing
stepping stones on real stones and it's
keeping its balance,
figuring out where to put the feet.
Um,
and again,
this robot only has stereo looking out
the front,
whereas this one has a stereo on all
four sides.
Now,
one of the cool things about animals is
that they have these stabilization
mechanisms for their sensors.
That was a real chicken,
no robotics involved and here's our
attempt to show that these,
this robot can do the same sort of thing
and if you think about it,
when you're manipulating,
you really want the hand to be
stabilized in space and so you'd like
the body to be able to kind of
coordinate with the hands so that you
can concentrate on what the world real
world task is.
A man,
you guys didn't pick up the banana
peels,
Huh?
So our concept for the spot many product
is to make a platform.
It's sort of the,
we're thinking of it like the android of
robots.
So with android there's a hardware
platform and then there's a software
platform and then a developer's third
party developers create their own apps
that use the platform.
So we've made this spot so that there's
a place to mount hardware on the robot,
but there's also an API to program it
through.
And then there's a facility to have
additional computing external to the
robot.
And we're working with third parties to
develop their own applications that run
on the platform.
Um,
this is a video that,
uh,
we haven't been able to release
publicly.
Please don't tape it and show it,
um,
because I can't,
I'll explain later if you want to know
why not,
but this is just a revealing that we do
have an arm on the,
on the new version of spot.
It's using a camera in the hand to find
the,
the door handle.
This robot doesn't weigh a lot,
so it has to use tricks to keep the door
open.
So that's why he puts his foot in the
door.
And here again,
we want to show that the,
we've made the solution robust to
certain kinds of disturbances.
So Andy,
there,
andy sitting over here is a pushing on
the door,
pushing on the hand.
The robot keeps track of how far,
how much progress it's made in doing its
task.
It's so,
it's so smart and even kicks that,
uh,
that shell out of the way.
Now that was total accident and now it's
just gone back to try again.
Okay.
Um,
and then this is a demo of autonomy.
A here are,
the robot has a,
in a previous session,
we've taken it around the lab.
This is Boston dynamics take into the
realm of lab and recorded visual data
that can be used for navigation and it's
using its stereo to match up features in
the environment so that they can
navigate a Ngo,
um,
where it had gone in the previous,
uh,
on the previous path.
So there's no one driving it for this.
It's all a,
uh,
autonomous that was outside my office
every day around noon.
The robot seems to show,
and I hear it pausing out there,
I don't know why it turned there as
sometimes it comes up with a solution
that isn't in here.
You'll see another one that comes up
with a solution that isn't cool,
why,
what call is an optimization,
but it does,
uh,
it does get a solution.
So we're pretty excited by this.
We call this patrol route and we're
working on developing a lot of software
to support it,
to make it so that other people can
capture a patrol route and then execute
them on a,
on a routine basis,
and then do the other tasks while
they're on the,
on the patrol route.
Seth,
you're on.
So we're now we'll do a demo of a spot
mini.
So for this,
for this demo,
Seth Scott,
a joystick and he's telling it the speed
to go in the forward direction and
turning,
but the robots doing all its own,
uh,
gates selection,
coordination of legs,
balance obviously.
So the robot has a bunch of different
gates that can walk here.
It's doing one leg at a time.
Um,
it can try it.
I know you do whatever gets you on set.
He's got to use the selected yet.
So here's trotting,
which is diagonal pairs of legs.
Um,
it can do pacing,
which is lateral pairs of legs to get
working together.
I have to tell you,
in the earliest days of me being
involved in legged locomotion,
I thought gate was a big deal,
but it's really kind of a small thing.
Um,
and I don't think it's central to what
matters,
which is support,
stability,
propulsion,
and things like that.
I'm going to wrap up shortly.
I just thought I'd say a couple of words
about the mechanical side.
Uh,
you know,
the atlas is a new version of a
humanoid.
Uh,
I know some of you worked with the Darpa
robotics challenge,
humanoid,
uh,
which was a big hulking thing that we
made and this is a much more svelte one.
And the way we got there was to uh,
work on,
uh,
the elements of the mechanical design to
take advantage of three d printing and,
uh,
some optimization.
And we did,
we focused on two or three different
things.
One is making some of the leg parts
where we embed hydraulic pathways,
hydraulic actuators,
places for valve mounts and filters and
things like that into the leg.
And this is what that looks like.
There's a single upper leg part that
incorporated 15 or 20 different separate
components in the previous design which
made it lighter,
more compact,
and a higher strength to weight ratio.
We also developed a hydraulic power
unit,
which takes many components.
The thing on the left are the components
as separate ones and we were able to
print parts that integrated them so that
there was a motor or a pump inside of a
motor,
an accumulator,
a reservoir,
valves,
filters and those things,
and we shrunk it down so that the robot
could be smaller and lighter.
And using that approach,
we went from about a 375 pound DRC robot
to a one 90 pound robot.
And then the current one is about a
hundred and 65 pounds.
Now this picture might lead you to
believe that I'm advertising myself as
only weighing 165 pounds.
And unfortunately that's not true,
but I'm working on it,
but it is close to my size and weight.
And,
uh,
I don't know.
I don't think we have this out as a
video.
Here's,
um,
uh,
some,
a robot behavior that uses whole body
motion,
meaning the mobility based plus the arms
plus the torso or all combining in order
to handle these,
uh,
these boxes.
It's using vision with the qr codes to
simplify the task here we're trying to
go at human speeds of operation.
And so the robot searches for a box
using its vision.
I think that,
I think that was the only take we ever
got with both robots working together
and uh,
you know,
one of the problems with youtube as
everybody's already seen what you've
been up to by the time you get it,
go around to give a talk.
So I imagine most of you have seen this,
but,
uh,
here's a,
a par core robot we're working on where,
uh,
we've actually strengthened the hips so
that it can do a little bit more jumping
and,
uh,
it's kind of interesting that we,
we've been interested in making a robot
a little bit like the humanoid that,
um,
has less degrees of freedom,
fewer degrees of freedom,
and a simpler.
And we designed this robot and the
ultimate version of this,
we'll have about 10 joints,
whereas the humanoid had 28 and have
many,
many of the same capabilities.
Uh,
we have,
uh,
some use cases for this that I'm not
going to talk about today.
Uh,
but,
uh,
this robot can lift heavy loads.
It has a relatively small footprint
given,
uh,
what his strength is.
So the way things are done in logistics
now is to use big robot arms that take
up a lot of floor area or heavy.
Um,
and uh,
we're looking at ways of using a robot
like this one,
not exactly this,
we,
it's sort of an evolution of this design
in order to do logistics operations.
So I want to make a pitch to you.
A Boston dynamics is hiring,
um,
and uh,
I hope some of you will apply for a job
there.
These are how many years?
It,
six times three.
These are 18,
um,
mit alum that currently work at the
company,
many of them for many years.
Uh,
so I'm sort of making the point that
these people are happy.
They're just like,
just like you could be.
And uh,
I hope you'll look at our website and
see what we're,
uh,
what we're looking for and considerate.
So I'm just going to wrap up by talking
about,
you know,
I used to be a professor here at
Carnegie Mellon and when I was a
professor will use the mostly wrote
papers and uh,
we were excited by,
uh,
you know,
how many papers we could,
right,
and how many people cited them,
uh,
in their papers.
But as a company guy instead of papers,
I think we count youtube hits a and
instead of citations want to tell you
what this is,
but most of you probably know.
So now we count.
Now we count spoofs instead of
citations.
And I'm happy to say that we're doing
great.
We have about,
uh,
about two dozen big dog spoofs.
Here's four of them.
In the upper left is in Akihabara,
Japan.
The upper right is a Los Angeles online
television show.
It's the Netherlands on the lower left.
And I guess that's Appalachia on the
right.
The poor kid doesn't even have a friend
to a to be in his movie.
Well,
what about,
what about atlas?
Can you hear that?
No.
Here's,
here's another one.
Thank you.
So we have,
we have a big crew working on all these
projects.
You see you've gotten to meet a couple
of them here,
but it's really quite a team in a,
uh,
an absolute pleasure to work with.
So anyway,
thank you.
Thank you.
Thanks for the presentation.
It was amazing.
Uh,
what sort of physics simulation,
like if any do you have in your robots
and do you really retain dead lake with
the current trend of neural networks?
We can just like do end to end modeling
of these robots,
but like without any sort of notion of
physics but just like neural networks.
Um,
so we have simulators that we've worked
on for a long time,
very detailed in some cases validated,
validated me and compare the behavior of
the simulator to the physics of,
of ground truth.
And uh,
you know,
I think they're important for our work
and we use them frequently,
but the end to end doesn't ring quite
true.
Usually the one we use simulation,
the user is knowledgeable about the
tradeoffs between doing a physical
experiment and doing a simulated
experiment and they're usually getting
at some specifically or specific setup
question rather than the idea that you
start at one end,
you know,
to at least in our experience trying to
simulate all the subtleties of the
hydraulic actuator,
backlashing gears a flexibility,
uh,
you know,
the non rigidity in the components,
that's a big undertaking and usually so,
so I'm distracting that you can't really
get on with what you're doing.
So I think we use experiment for those
subtleties and we use simulation for a
bigger level dynamics questions.
Hey,
would you say mechanical concerns or
computational capability is more of a
difficulty in terms of determining how
quickly you can perform tasks with the
robots?
Um,
you know,
we like to say that they're equally
important.
We,
we now,
although we didn't start out this way,
we now have equal strength in our groups
in mechanical design and implementation
and in the software and controls and
sensing.
And I think,
you know,
they all matter.
I think if you try and get by with just
marginally designed hardware,
uh,
you don't get much experimental time in
because the thing's broken all the time.
Uh,
so even though we are rough on our
machines,
they mostly keep working because,
because we put a lot of attention to
detail and how they're designed.
Uh,
but you know,
there's still the,
I think perception is still a tall pole
in the tent.
Certainly if you want to rival human
perception,
I don't think we're anywhere near there.
I said I think the self driving car
stuff is helping.
Uh,
there's a lot of interesting things
happened there.
I think specialized hardware is getting,
you know,
a,
a six and,
and things that could help.
Um,
but you know,
it's,
it's all still needed.
So,
um,
you guys have developed various
components that all kind of come
together to build one robot.
Have you seen applications for any of
these separate components elsewhere?
So a organic design,
for example,
for the atlas,
maybe prosthetics or hip replacements or
something like that because there seems
to be a lot of development going on and
then individually as well as that they
pay.
Sure.
I mean,
you're asking a very good question.
There's a question in case people
couldn't hear his are,
aside from the value to the whole robot
of the components we're making,
are the components useful some other
way.
And uh,
you know,
the,
the place where we think it's probably
most true is the specialized hydraulic
components.
We've made servo valves and uh,
the HPU,
I'm sure we could sell them into other
industry,
uh,
as a,
as a company focused question though,
uh,
that that's really what it comes to.
Do we really want to be doing that?
Will that absorb too much time and
attention and personnel or do we want
to,
you know,
our heart is really in building a future
generations of robots.
So I think we're going to probably stay
there.
Okay.
Thanks.
I was wondering,
have you done any research in regards to
getting the robots to perform tasks
involving direct physical contact with
humans?
Nope,
I can.
Only.
The only thing we've done is we've done
tele operation,
which is not what you mean,
where we have a human moving and the
robot,
you know,
copying,
which is very interesting because,
uh,
you can see that that's a way of showing
how fast the robot can be and how
coordinated they can be using a human
and for part of the computing,
uh,
but we have,
we don't have them interacting with
people.
I guess the closest as we once did a
thing where a person and a robot picked
up a stretcher and work together to pick
up the stretcher,
but they weren't touching each other.
They going through the,
uh,
the stretcher material.
We have plans,
uh,
you know,
we're really,
to be honest,
we're really struggling with coming up
with some strong concepts for safety.
Even without doing that,
um,
you know,
robots,
uh,
it's,
you know,
your first real people's first reaction
and how you make a robot safe if there's
a problem,
don't really work very well.
You can't freeze the robot,
uh,
you have to find some,
you have to keep them going.
I find a way to get into a safer state.
So I think having come in contact with
people is just gonna be harder.
So eventually we want to,
to help to carry the lift,
the elderly and things like that.
But we're not there yet.
Um,
my question is about the relative rates
of progress in robotics and machine
intelligence.
So an economist might maybe measure it
by seeing how much money is going into
computing hardware versus arms and legs
centers naturally,
that kind of thing.
Um,
so on one one possible scenario,
the um,
the machine intelligence receives the
head and the robots a progressing more
slowly because of a kind of a slow build
test cycle.
Basically it's,
they will well things,
it's not so easy to get a rapid build
test cycle with a robot.
And then the other scenario,
the robots are more advanced than the
machine intelligence.
Machine intelligence is just such a
conceptually difficult problem.
So I'm in one side of the machines are
telling the humans want to do in the
other scenario that humans telling the
machines what to do if you'd like.
Um,
so do you have any kind of perspective
on that whole issue with the machine
intelligence folk going to rush ahead
using robots,
guys struggling behind or the robot's
going to get there before the massive
problem and machine intelligence get
sold or maybe somewhere in the middle
I think.
Let's see.
I don't know exactly what you mean by
machine intelligence.
Are you talking about um,
you know,
having Google do better search.
So we were intelligent
mutation in general.
So I start,
I talked about economists measuring
sensors,
actuators,
and compute hardware.
So that's the kind of split I'm thinking
about.
Yeah,
I think that it's always been a
misconception that the hardware
components by themselves,
uh,
constitute progress in intelligence or
in robot behavior.
Uh,
they're,
I think they're important ingredients.
But by themselves,
you know,
when I was a graduate student here,
I can remember reading an ad for a,
an uh,
uh,
optical character recognition system and
what the ad said was,
uh,
you know,
we have camera,
we have a thing for holding the paper.
You're looking at,
all you have to do is write the
software.
So it was all done except for you to
write the software.
And uh,
you know,
it's the whole problem was there.
So I don't know if I'm answering your
question.
Uh,
you know,
robotics is hard.
Uh,
I think it feels like we're making
progress if you keep pushing,
we keep making progress.
It's not like there's a knee in the
curve that we've hit a.
But I also think that the rest of the ai
world is making a good progress too.
And yeah,
it's fun being a part of it.
Hi,
my question is mostly related to
security.
Uh,
so since you are productizing your
robots now,
um,
there has been research on the lidars
mainly,
uh,
where you could spoof allied are and,
and the sensor basically cannot see
anything.
Uh,
so are you looking into that as well,
taking into consideration these awesome
robots could be in let's say in our
defense,
you know,
working for the defense as well.
So those are like really harsh
environments.
Yeah,
I mean these are very hard problems,
you know,
if someone,
if a,
if an intelligent adversary wants to
trick the robot,
it's not all that hard,
uh,
these days,
you know,
we're,
we're working probably the other end of
the problem,
you know,
trying to do the basics.
Uh,
right now,
uh,
I don't think,
you know,
I don't,
I don't think robots are going to be as
autonomous in a hostile environment as,
as people either think or fear,
uh,
because uh,
of how frail they'll still be a until we
get further along.
Hi there.
Hey,
I wanted to ask about two things that
are going to probably play a big role in
adoption.
The first is price,
so if you could speak to the current
unit price of a spot,
many and how that you think is going to
evolve over time.
And the second is sort of consumer
psychology.
Uh,
I felt like when I saw the,
um,
the,
the test at the end of the robot
swearing my level of comfort with it
being in my house suddenly shot up
because it seemed way more human.
So I was just thinking about what kinds
of experiments you guys have run away,
what you've thought about with respect
to making people more comfortable with
robots working around them.
Yeah.
Uh,
in terms of costs,
I,
you know,
we're not saying what this thing costs
yet,
but we will later in the year,
um,
we have reduced the cost of this by
about a factor of 10 from what the first
prototypes cost.
So we're making progress.
Um,
in terms of the psychology of robots,
it's been very interesting to watch,
you know,
we uh,
we got branded sort of as robot abusers
because we kicked our robot.
Really what we were doing was trying to
show how good they were at balancing and
we weren't,
we didn't think we were abusing him.
I have video of me pushing on my
daughter when she was one years old and
actually knocking her over,
but that wasn't my goal.
I wanted to kind of test out her her
balance and uh,
uh,
I bet you,
you know,
if you guys have kids or you're or at
all that you've done stuff like that.
Um,
so,
but we've adjusted a little bit and so
we don't usually push on the robots in
our videos despite the one we showed
with the hockey and hockey sticking a
hand on this thing.
Uh,
that's why we had the banana peels.
There's a way to have the robot crash
without us being having our fingerprints
on it.
Um,
you know,
I guess the other data point I have is
that if you look at the likes and
dislikes on our youtube videos,
um,
we found a way to get the likes to
dislikes ratio much higher by partly
probably by not looking like we're
abusing the,
uh,
the robots.
Um,
there's probably a long way to go to
make these things really friendly.
Um,
and uh,
uh,
I have to admit there's a little spirit
at our,
at our company of being kind of a,
you know,
it's fun being bad boys in terms of uh,
just make the robot do cool stuff and
leave the,
uh,
the emotions to others.
Um,
and certainly the social robots that
have so much going into making them
cute.
Uh,
I don't know.
I'm sure we'll have marketing people
working on that.
I don't know what else to say.
Hi.
So in terms of research purpose,
our practical purposes,
so one of the reasons to choose to
investigate on this,
um,
humanoid robots.
So it seems like,
um,
it cannot run as fast as the Cheetah and
the,
it also cannot carry as many staff as
the big dog.
Yeah.
You're basically saying that the
humanized don't seem to be as practical
in terms of function
more efficient,
like a,
like a humanoid robot is more efficient
than these are cheaters and the big box.
Well,
the motivated.
So I don't have a good answer.
Uh,
the motivation for the DRC that Darpa
robotics challenge,
which was humanoid robots,
was to say that they wanted to use
robots that could go the places designed
for humans.
And uh,
and so that's why they used the human
form.
And I think,
you know,
there's an argument there.
Uh,
it is true that the,
uh,
human form has a lot of complexity to it
because you have very complicated legs
in the IPAD and they're supporting the
weight of the body and the arms,
whereas the quieter beds can spread all
that out.
I'm,
uh,
so I'm sympathetic to your question.
I don't really have an answer.
Um,
I can tell you that the public's
reaction to a humanoid robot is off the
scale compared to anything we've done
with a quadrupedal robots for what
that's worth.
So,
uh,
we always get a lot of viewership if we
show a human doing something.
Uh,
but I think it's a question that we will
keep addressing.
We are gonna keep pushing on getting the
humanoid to do more and more human,
like things.
Uh,
even though we probably won't
commercialize them as soon as we
commercialize the other stuff,
how do you specify goals?
And although you said earlier that it's
expensive to do like simulations and
stuff,
do you have any intentions of doing any
deep reinforcement learning?
What was the last time?
Do you have any intentions of doing deep
reinforcement learning?
Um,
I'll do the last one first.
we,
I'm sure we will use learning before too
long.
Uh,
I'm not sure whether it will be deep
reinforcement learning or something
else,
but mostly we're interested in
optimizing the complicated a stage space
partitioning.
We do a right now we use,
you know,
people make a very simple decisions as
to how to divide up the space and we
think that these things could probably
be a really improved if we,
uh,
use the learning approach,
that's probably the first place we will
apply it.
We do a little bit of learning here and
there,
but not much compared to how much
learning is talked about out there.
What was the other question?
How do we specify a goal?
You mean to the robot or how do we
decide as a company?
So,
um,
I don't think there's any across the
board answer.
We write applications,
for instance,
for each of these uses.
So for instance,
in the,
uh,
where we were doing the patrol route,
we have an application that has a Ui
that lets the user,
uh,
you know,
tell it the information it needs to
tell,
can tell it to go ahead and start on the
patrol.
Uh,
and things like that.
Um,
for,
for the door,
I think,
uh,
there's a button on the,
on the controller we can show you
afterwards if you want.
And uh,
you walk the robot up to the door,
were you steering it and then you press
the button and then it starts looking
for the door handle and it goes through
the whole,
you know,
goes through the door.
But I don't think these answers are
fundamental.
I think you could do it lots of
different ways.
You know,
we're working on all the machinery
coming up from the bottom to be able to
do these things.
And then,
you know,
in some case you could have it be
buttons on a,
on a Ui,
it could be a,
an API that's accessed through some
higher level ai,
uh,
and we just aren't sweating that part of
it at this point.
Hi.
Um,
so aside from locomotion,
um,
I can use my body for like nonverbal
communication to communicate my
intentions and other such things,
even though I'm not always aware of it.
Um,
and I'm guess I'm wondering if this is
something that you've considered for
these robots.
I think the we've come is having the
robot go like this after the flip,
which was a way of communicating a,
we really haven't done anything along
those lines.
I'll bet you though the people writing
code,
uh,
it can interpret it a lot of the
subtleties of what's,
you know,
what's working and what isn't by looking
at things like that.
But the robot isn't trying to
communicate that way.
I have two questions.
How robots really,
really fast.
How do we make them fast?
No,
my question is how did you make them
fast?
I mean like the time how,
where you get a lot of people who are
really smart and good at working
together with each other at our lab and
then they make plans and a,
which everybody tries to stay on the
plan and then,
uh,
you know,
pull it together.
Sometimes it doesn't go as fast as we'd
like,
especially if we have to buy parts from
someone else and they're slow.
That happens a lot,
honestly.
A,
is that what you mean?
So we don't make them that fast,
you know,
we're,
we're pretty fast,
you know,
usually I'm four or five months to build
a new robot.
Um,
something like that.
But mostly it's getting people to work
together.
What's the,
what's the other question?
The other question is why do the people
push the robots?
Why did,
why do they push,
why do they push?
We're trying.
The robots are always balancing them
themselves and so we want to show that
they're,
that they can balanced by,
by,
um,
showing that when you knock them,
they still,
they don't fall over,
they stay up on their feet.
So we're kind of showing off.
Are you building anything?
Why not?
You should,
um,
it's way off what we were in the
basement.
I'm not good at building.
No.
Yes.
Yes you are.
You might think you're not.
Some games they are.
You had to give it a try.
You're the right age.
The right age to get started.
I'm six and a half.
Okay.
Would that,
I think please give mark a big hand.
Thank you very much.